hi there so what you're looking at here
is a weather forecast model specifically
the very top row is a new weather
forecast model called net net by Google
research so the goal of weather
prediction is pretty simple you want to
know what the weather is gonna be in the
future it's specifically here you want
to know precipitation rates and so this
is a new work that uses neural network
instead of physical models in order to
predict precipitation so in the middle
here you see this is the ground truth of
what really happened at that particular
time you see precipitation rates in red
here moving across the country now the
bottom there is a physical model and as
far as I understand that physical models
have been used so far to make weather
predictions which basically means that
you simulate these these rain clouds and
the movement of them across the country
and you do physical simulation like a
particle simulation type of thing and
then that allows you to predict and then
you run that maybe multiple times and
you get an idea of the kind of
distribution you're gonna get
now what metnet does is it simply uses a
neural network to predict the outcome
directly so there's no physical
simulation involved right there is just
a neural network that takes as input
what's the situation now and maybe over
a stretch of time and then you ask it
please make a prediction in eight hours
or something and then the net-net will
make that prediction and it will just
output it like you know snap no physical
simulation needed and you also see here
that method outputs things in kind of a
cloud way in a probabilistic way in one
forward pass you don't need to run it
multiple times but we'll get to that on
the bottom here
you see the measurement so the axis is
f1 f1 is kind of the the overlap of the
how well you're able to predict a
precipitation and you seer the net-net
is above the HR our baseline for most of
this time up to 480 minutes into the
future right which is 8 hours I believe
all right so um the paper is the
following
it's called net net a neural weather
model for precipitation forecasting and
I'm not going to read all the names here
the mean corresponding authors are
Casper case under B and now tout
brighter and it's a team of Google
research so specifically they use the
input of these two things here so one is
this it goes 16 which is what you see
here on the left and the precipitation
rates are here depicted on the right so
you want to take these things as input
into your model now how do you do that
of course we're going to build a neural
network and this is the architecture
they come up with so on the bottom here
they feed in the data and they feed in
the data in 15 minute interval from 90
minutes into the past so you have to
imagine it like this so there's a
timeline it's a little bit of a finer
thing there is a timeline and you let's
say are here this is now and then here
in the future this is maybe one hour
into the future this is your target
right this is you are here and you're
looking out you would like to know
what's the the precipitation going to be
in one hour from now
what Mitnick does is it takes a so
called takes an input
and specifically it takes the last 90
minutes before now as an input and it
samples it in frequencies of 15-minute
intervals right so each one of these is
going to be 15 minutes and each 15
minutes you get like a snapshot of this
entire of of the input region now the
input region if I can jump back here to
the website for a second they show it
what the input region is the input
region if you want to predict in the
middle of this small square the input
region is actually the entire 1,024
where kilometers around it so it's a
very big input though the actual region
you consider is the inside 64 square
kilometers but you take in information
from the big region and the main point
of the paper I believe is how to do that
all right
so each 15 minutes you take in a
snapshot and these are these snapshots
here on the bottom so these are and you
have to imagine in here every 15 minutes
there's a stack of these inputs so what
are these inputs these inputs are some
kind of features that you have so there
is the target time which in this case
would be this one hour here there is the
month day and hour which is important
for weather prediction right so the time
of year time of day and so on
longitude latitude is probably pretty
important elevation map is probably
pretty important so these you can see
these are all maps now some times and
this is how you encode things in these
since it's a neural network you know all
of these things must be of the same
dimensions here so if you have 256
dimensions here and probably 256
dimensions here then all of these things
must be of the same dimension and if you
want to give a feature such as the
target time
which in this case let's say it's one
hour so you just put here one hour
what's one hour let's say 60 minutes so
you just put the number 60 here sixty
sixty sixty sixty sixty two hundred and
fifty six times and 256 x 256 t5 sorry
265 times now 56 I'm confusing with
German so this is how you encode the
features is pretty primitive but it
turns out it works the best if you do it
this way alright so you have these
planes and some as I said are just
features such as the target time month
day an hour and so on elevation I guess
is a map is like an elevation map of the
region you consider and this corresponds
now to this these 64 kilometers x 64
kilometers here and that's exactly what
these Center crops are here so this
centre crop thing that now this this
thing here this plane sorry is these 64
by 64 region that's this plane here and
also the that's for the precipitation
and the geo yes that's this thing here
now we also have these down sampled
things which these are the 1,024
kilometers so this here and this here
these are the 1,024 square kilometer
patches but they are down sampled so
everything is down sampled I guess to
256 by 256 pixels so you don't really
take into account every nuance of that
very big of that very big input but you
do down sampling so you can get the big
picture of the outer frame and in the
inner frame you take it in a much higher
resolution in order to get the details
all right
so you
back all of this up into a big tensor
and you feed it into here into a spatial
down sampler which I guess no I have
read is a simplistic convolutional
neural network right so this is your
typical image processing pipeline so you
do this for each of these stacks right
and then what you get out of it is a is
a is a lower size representation right
here so you get these representations
and then you let a temporal encoder run
over it what does the temporal encoder
do this in particular is a convolutional
l STM and if you already know what an
ALICE TM is a convolutional l STM is
nothing more than an LS TM that has as
intermediate layers convolutional layers
so it's pretty suited to do for example
videos or any sort of image processing
that goes over time like this one so the
temporal encoder simply starts out here
with an initial state my pins are
screwing me today so it started here
with an initial state and then it simply
inputs each of these representations
takes them one by one runs across time
right and each time producing a new
intermediate representation of the of
the input until it finally reaches this
here final representation so this thing
here is a single final representation of
all of this input right of this entire
of this entire time span of all of these
stacks here yeah so you compress this
into a single input with first a
convolutional Network to down sample
each time point individually and then
with an recurrent neural network in LS
TM to integrate the information over
time you end up with the single piece
here and then what you do
so you still here you still retain kind
of an image sort of thing so this this
this representation here you can see it
in the background maybe I get Thomas
scribbles here this here is still sort
of an image tensor though I guess it's a
hidden representation so you couldn't
really look at it but it is it still has
dimensions of images so this here is
still I I think the same or
corresponding to these dimensions here
so this has still has some spatial
information where this might be
north-south here and this axis might be
east and west right and then these are
just they're hidden channels the
channels of the hidden representations
right so what you would like to do now
is is to basically encode information
from the space around you if you look at
let's look at one of these one of the
big pictures what you would like to do
in weather prediction let's say you are
right here what's a good color you are
right here right now if you want to know
if this this particular cloud over here
is going to move to your direction what
you want to know is for example is there
a mountain range here right because then
it's more probable that this cloud is
going maybe to move up there you would
also want to know how this cloud here
moves right
if this cloud here moves somewhere here
around then it's probably this cloud
down here might be pulled with it or
something like this so you're very much
sorry you're there you're very much kind
of want to look out into each of the
directions here
and you want to incorporate and what's
happening across the space we're already
used to kind of convolutional networks
being able to do this but in here the
authors use attention to do that so if
you don't know what attention is my most
popular video is about attention and you
can do attention for images so the way
that works is that you have a series of
images of stacked blocks of a neural
network let me draw this here so you
have an image here and let's say it has
just four pixels right so you have the
next layer of these four pixels right to
have layers of this so the next layers
of the four pixels they all emit what
are called queries and queries are just
a vector so each pixel emits a single
vector let's say this that that this
right and each of the lower layers emits
what is called a key this this this this
and now the keys and the queries are
routed together based on their inner
product so these two would be routed
together this would probably be routed
here this is well this would probably
route it here so what in effect each of
the pixels of the higher layer can look
at specific pixels of the lower layer
now you can imagine this is exactly what
we want here in that if there is a
mountain range here and we might be
interested in that
so we be able from our from our point
here to specifically attend to that
location using using attention right so
the authors here build basically a
stacked model of attention layers that's
what's happening in the third part here
this is the attention is in order to
incorporate long-ranged
as I made the example with the mountain
range this might be far away but it
might actually influence your weather
very much so the attention is to
incorporate these long-range
dependencies but the problem with
attention is is as you saw in the
example each of these pixels can attend
to each of the pixels in the lower layer
so what you'd end up with so each can
attend to that this can attend to each
this can attend to each you'll see
you'll end up with 16 connections can't
even draw them so you end up with 16
connections in general if you have D
here you will end up with a d squared
number of things you need to calculate
right so if this here and now of course
we have images so generally we'll think
of D by D pixels now we have D by D
pixels and that thing squared number of
things we need to calculate this quickly
gets too much so in for example M nest
you have a 28 by 28 F 28 by 28 pixel
images this is 780 s of 2 or something I
don't quite remember but you will have
to calculate this squared many
connections between things
this is employee gets impossible pretty
quickly especially if you scale up the
images and then have some channels in
here as well so attention for image
processing has been a bit lagging
compared to natural language processing
in natural language processing usually
have maybe 500 tokens or something
images you have much more so attention
is much more expensive so you can't
really do it on current hardware now
this paper uses something called axial
attention
axial tension is kind of the trick of
how to make these this tension happen
for images and for that I want to switch
over to this paper it's called axial
attention in multi-dimensional
transformers by some of the same authors
so Jonathan the hall and knockout
Brenner also of Google brain and UC
Berkeley and they proposed this axial
transformer now they originally proposed
actual axial attention for auto
regressive models if you know
transformers they also started by making
auto regressive models so language
modeling and so on but if we can
decouple the axial attention from the
auto regressive 'ti of these models so
I'm not going to talk about auto
regressive model is just axial attention
so what is axial attention it's pretty
simple actually and I want to start by
talking about convolutions so what does
the convolution do let's just take a one
dimensional image which is pretty boring
but let's say it has these eight pixels
here right so this is an image it just
has one row of eight pixels right what
do I do when I do when I run a
convolutional filter across that this is
the lower layer and now this is the next
layer that is produced by a convolution
so for each of the pixels in the next
layer what I can do with the
convolutional layer I can look at its
neighbors in the lower layer right so
these three would be part of that and
then I go on to this and again I look at
its neighbors at these three right I
might end this in a different color and
then I look at this and it can look at
itself and its neighbors right so a
convolution is pretty smart and then of
course
in the next layer that repeats now if
you think what what's the difference
between doing this and a fully connected
layer so if I have a fully connected
layer you know classic neural network
fully connected layer then this pixel
here would incorporate information from
all of the pixels here right and this
pixel here would incorporate information
from all the pixels now why is might
this be better because you know the
information that I want here for this
pixel might depend on this pixel over
here so I might benefit from a
connection over there or it might
benefit from sorry from this pixel here
right which you can't reach and with a
convolutional network I can't do that
why are then convolutional networks
preferable because the convolutional
network can do the same thing across
multiple layers right so let's assume
again that this pixel here needs
information from this pixel right here
and as you can see in just one layer it
can only get information from those
right but now take the next layer so the
same pixel here it can attend to these
three right now these three can each
turn attend to eat their neighbors right
and I'm not going to draw everything but
the resolution field for this pixel here
will end up being all of this right now
we still don't have our desired pixel in
here but if we just go one layer more
then this pixel right here in a
different color the
pixal right here right the resolution
field across the layers increases
because it's always incorporating
information from downstream and the
downstream again incorporates
information from the downstream so
eventually you can aggregate the same
information so instead of having a
single layer with all of these
connections we have convolutional layers
which seemed like it worse idea because
they can only do less things attend to
less things but across layers they
actually can do the same thing right and
that turns out to be a huge advantage of
these convolutional layers and that's
why convolutional layers are used for
image processing and not the multi-layer
perceptrons so the same exact thing
happens with axial attention just in a
different form it is a bit poorly drawn
here I believe but this is how you have
to imagine it as before right this pixel
the red pixel here if I had just have a
normal transformer layer the red pixel
can attend to all of the other pixels in
the image right that's the that's
basically and each of the pixels can do
that so that's the or d squared
computation right here now what we want
to do is you know in a convolutional
layer what we would do is okay you can
only attend to your neighbors and then
in the next layer the neighbors can
attend to their neighbors and thereby
you go out and out in axial attention
you say okay this thing can only attend
to its row and it's column right that's
it you can only do attention to your row
and your column and I believe they don't
even do it at the same time so in one
layer you can tend to
the role you're in and in the other you
can attend to the column you're in now
let's see how the same thing happens as
for a convolutional layer it's in the
basically how then if the red pixel
needs access to information in this
green pixel how does it do that
so in the first layer it can attend to
its row and it's column right and so can
every other pixel including sorry
including of course the pixel where that
so let's say this square here can also
attend to its row and it's column and
it's row happens to be including the
green one right so in layer one this red
square here gets information from the
green square via row attention right and
then in layer two
now this our red square of interest now
can row attend to this other red square
here so they get connected in layer two
I'm sorry I don't want that so you see
that within just two layers we've
transferred information from the green
square via this Red Square to that red
square so we can the same way as a
convolution you can replace the
long-range arbitrary dependencies
between pixels by simply having multiple
layers of restricted dependence the same
goes for this axial attention so you can
replace the arbitrary attention in
layers right you can replace that by by
a twos
process where you first transfer
information via the column and then
transfer it via the row it's a bit like
you know in chess you can have a queen
that can move any direction especially
diagonally and then if you just have a
rook you kind of need to do two moves so
in the the queen is like the full
attention and the rook is the
multi-layer axial attention they can
achieve the same thing you just need
more layers but as a trade-off you get a
super super saving in requirement of
memory and computation right so they
stress that you know kind of you can
represent the the same distributions
with the axial attention if you and you
know that the trade-off is you just have
to do multiple layers of it right so
this is axial attention and they are now
able to incorporate this into their
model right here so they have I believe
eight blocks so for row attention you
see this right here and for column
attention blocks in their model and
finally they output a they output this
distribution here across their region of
interest now this again is your I
believe this 64 by 64 resolution so you
can see how they kind of aggregated
information across the 64 using this
axial attention and then that makes
their prediction in in this one hour so
this is this alright so this this was a
long way so recap they have 15 minutes
nap shots of these is this input data
across along with some features they use
a spatial down sampler which is a CNN on
each of them individually then they use
a convolutional lsdm to encode
across time to end up with a single
representation here at the end then they
use axial attention in order to
aggregate information across the spatial
dimensions they do this in multiple
stages and at the end they make a
participation prediction which is is a
distribution as you can see here so as
an output you directly get a
distribution of results which is also
cool because the physical simulation you
have to let it run many many times in
order to get a distribution of results
and this neural network can simply give
you a distribution right away that's
what they say right here so they go bit
into the architecture compared to
baseline I want to get back to what I've
shown you at the beginning and this here
is just the picture and kind of the
picture book example so left is the
ground truth in the middle is mat net
and on the right is a baseline method
[Music]
and this here is in as you can see in 2
hours in 4 6 & 8 so you can see the met
that gives you as an actus distribution
when I find interesting for example is
this sample 2 right here so in this
sample 1 you can see there is a
consistent difference and this is the
forecast time so how much in advance you
wanna know this would be a was our 1
hour but it can go up to 8 hours here is
a consistent gap in F 1 which means the
met net does it better
across this span of time which is for
the top sample right here
for the bottom sample though you can see
here there is a big gap at the beginning
again there is a big gap at the
beginning and then this gap gets smaller
and smaller and smaller
and this I think might give you an
indication of let's say the weakness of
this approach doing it with neural
networks so with neural networks you
kind of rely on regularities you kind of
rely on broad scale correct things that
you can learn from the data and this
might work well as as long as things are
regular which of course across shorter
time spans things tend to be more
regular right but if you go for longer
time spans I believe there is more of a
chaos element to it like whether can can
be very dependent on very subtle things
and the physics simulation that is
really you know taking to account the
actual physics might be able to much
much better account for that and that's
why I believe across time here you'll
see you see that the two models get
closer together not being said met and
of course still on top here but it will
be interesting to to forecast for for a
longer even though I haven't actually
dig through their results through their
numerical results but you can do that if
you want all right so this was it for
maintenance and axial attention I hope
you like this and bye-bye